foreign
to Brilliant Minds bold questions my
name is Daniel bacinello and I'm
director of research at sea farm the
Canadian Institute for advanced research
coming on the heels of celebrating our
40th year today's event is part of
cfar's virtual talks the series explores
questions that are addressed by some of
the world's top researchers each talk
pairs speakers moderators from across
disciplined sectors and the world to
explore questions shaping our future
cfar is a canadian-based global research
organization that convenes extraordinary
Minds to address the most important
questions facing science and Humanity
we bring Canada to the world and the
world to Canada we convene 400
researchers from 141 institutions in 20
countries our fellows chairs Scholars
and advisors are among the most highly
cited in the world including 20 Nobel
Prize laureates and three touring Award
winners and now it is my absolute
pleasure to introduce you to Maggie
Osborne and Jason studich our speakers
for today
Maggie is a fellow in our Earth 4D
subsurface science and exploration
program and an associate professor at
Northwestern University
she is a geobiologist who is interested
in understanding interactions between
microbes and the Earth
Jason is a CFR fellow in our fungal
Kingdom threat and opportunities program
and a professor at the University of
California Riverside he's a
bioinformatician interested in the
mechanisms of evolution of fungi
today we'll be discussing the knowns and
unknowns about the Earth's subsurface
and Life In The Deep biosphere
our session will last 45 minutes as
moderator I will ask our speakers
questions and we'll also be taking
questions from all of you joining us
today at the end of the discussion if
you'd like to participate please submit
a question through the Q a function at
the bottom of your screen
lastly this session is being recorded
and will be available next week on the
cfar website at cfar.ca as such you're
welcome to re-watch the session or share
it with your colleagues
so to start off Maggie and Jason can you
please tell us a little bit about your
own individual work Maggie
thank you Daniel it's a pleasure to be
here
um my work sits at the intersection
between microbiology and geochemistry
and I'm fundamentally interested and
fascinated by the interactions between
microorganisms the microbial biosphere
and the Earth itself so the geosphere
and how they both influence each other
both in the modern environment and then
as we go into the deep time record
um as a geoscientist my lab uses a
variety of tools including things like
DNA sequencing but also things like
lipid biomarkers which are really
important to make that leap between the
modern and ancient environments and uh
thank you Daniel and it's really great
to be here as well my research sits um
at that interface of how fungi interact
with the environment and other organisms
and we use genomic tools
um as well as comparative and
evolutionary tools to try to understand
the functions of how uh fungi grow and
live and to study their biology and both
from the molecular scale of those cells
as well as a more broad environmental
sampling to study where the fungi are
found and some of those questions relate
to how fungi act as pathogens on animals
or plants but also how fungi interact in
extreme environments where water may be
limited or uh where where temperatures
May fluctuate and so using both these
genomic and and uh experimental tools we
try to understand their biology
so these sound like two different areas
of focus between your two research
groups so can you describe a little bit
about the kind of work that you two are
doing together
sure so um this is again a product of
the of the cfar uh teams that uh we've
been able to come together as part of
our fungal Kingdom theme and interact
with the Earth's uh 4D team and uh what
we wanted to understand is these deep
subsurface environments have been
characterized mostly for the bacterial
and archaeal communities but less so for
the the fungal and so
um bringing our expertise on on fungal
biology and and diversity to the
sampling and the bio geochemistry
questions that are being asked by the
Earth 4D team has been a great chance to
try to blend and and find
interdisciplinary uh strengths between
all of these questions and so it's a
it's a chance to both culture fungi and
sequence try to sequence environment
from these environments to study uh what
might be there
great so the the title of this talk
today though is life in the Deep
biosphere so what do we mean when we
talk when we say deep biosphere what are
we really talking about here and how
deep is deep is there really life down
there
well that's a bit of a controversial
question Daniel and the answer depends
largely on who you ask
um and comes a little bit with the
history of how this field developed
um so humans that interact with the Deep
environment which admittedly is not
everyone
um have known for a long time that there
are microbes down there so in sort of
early petroleum development there was
this knowledge that if you added the
wrong thing to a reservoir it would sour
and you wouldn't make any money
um now we understand that that's the
process of microbial sulfate reduction
um even as early as the 30s there are
mentions of like microbes bacteria in
that case in old rocks where they maybe
shouldn't be the research really picked
up in so the last three decades focusing
on both the marine and the terrestrial
deep subsurface and so when we're
thinking about the Marine subsurface our
knowledge of this has expanded through
things like the iodp programs and the
ODP before that where we drill cores of
sediment and count the cells in there
and there were seminal papers in the 90s
that essentially were like whoa this is
big this is really exciting and
interesting and those have been refined
and there was like 201 was sort of this
amazing Cruise focused just on
understanding the life in the deeper
rain subsurface
understanding life in the terrestrial
deep subsurface has paralleled that in
some ways but has focused on more
practical applications and is moving to
deeper and deeper terrains as we move
forward so there was development
thinking about life in more the
shallower aquifers and so as as recently
as sort of the 80s late 80s early 90s
people would have told you there's a
depth Threshold at which it's sterile
we've moved our thinking and progressed
to a place where there's really more of
a temperature threshold and a porosity
permeability threshold but there's been
lots of focus on both sedimentary
terrains and deep crystalline terrains
and we're going deeper and deeper every
day so below the soils arguably below
the soils and then as deep as
temperature allows and there is
absolutely life down there it turns out
it's actually far harder to find an
environment that doesn't have any life
in it than one that does
so
and and just to build on that I think um
the work has been to study what fungi
might live deeper has been maybe not not
quite as extensive but uh you know
efforts to look in caves it's
interesting to find you know very deep
uh caves uh find fungi in soils and very
deep caves as well as find fungi in mind
where perhaps they were brought in on
pieces of wood and you can find them
still able to to survive in those those
deeper environments but for the truly
deep biosphere
um again it's life is probably existing
within with inside rocks or or in these
crevices
um but the the sampling uh and and the
actual study of these eukaryotic cells
has been limited and so
um trying to understand how they might
move how they might get down into these
places or how much
um uh how much motion there is to allow
them to gain uh a niche to hold into and
whether or not that's been cut off from
the rest of the the surface or if
there's a there's a constant influx so
depending on the kind of environment
being studied a different fungi might be
inhabiting those but as you can see it's
it's a bit of a new frontier for trying
to understand that
so I'm convinced there's there's
definitely life down there but so can I
ask how does life do we find in the Deep
biosphere differ from the life we're
maybe more familiar with on the
terrestrial surface
so one places we've been looking to try
to understand fungi in kind of extreme
environments where there's low
availability of of nutrients are places
like Antarctica or uh in the some of the
Atacama deserts and some of the dry
environments where water is particularly
a limiting resource and what we find is
that fungi are growing or can be found
growing inside rocks
um and even though the surface of the
rock might not have any observable
microbial life
um often when we break open that rock
and we culture or we do amplicon
sequencing where we use PCR to to
amplify markers from that that would
indicate uh the kinds of microbes that
are there we can find fungi that are
related to or are lichenized fungi so
even though there isn't an observable
lichen on the surface we sometimes or
often can find
um fungi that look like lichens inside
um and um but interestingly we can find
fungi and other dry environments like
the space station or in the rooms
in NASA where where there's efforts to
really eradicate all microbial life but
the fungi often have these very thick
spores and ability to kind of stay in
stasis for a long time until that water
is available and so understanding the
adaptations that allow these fungi to be
persist for a long time one other really
interestingly crazy place to find fungi
is even inside the damaged um Chernobyl
uh reactor that you can find fungi
growing on the walls in there
um where most other microbial life has
been excluded and so again the
um the ability to kind of thrive in a
niche where maybe there's there's an
opening is is something that fungi can
uh can take advantage of
yeah so there's some commonality when we
think about the bacterial and the
archaeal populations and the subsurface
as what Jason just said about the fungi
you're not typically talking about life
bacterial life as you might find it in
say a philosophy coli on your lab bench
or you know something going bad in your
fridge you're thinking about a much more
energy limited and particularly carbon
limited kind of ecosystem and so people
often talk about life in the slow lane
or slow life as ways of thinking about
deep subsurface microbiology and what we
mean by that is that
um either in Marine sediments you're
living in an environment where the the
nutrients and the resources are being
progressively used up as that package of
sediment is buried over thousands to
millions of years and so we're talking
about an incredibly long time scales and
so those organisms are persisting and
adapting and sort of you know getting
the last ditch of energy out of that
system
when we think about the terrestrial deep
subsurface biosphere when we're in uh
more Dynamic aquifers and rocks and more
Dynamic aquifers and rocks in the ocean
as well you're thinking about organisms
that have the ability to use resources
as they come along and so long periods
of dormancy or stasis or sort of
metabolic modes that we don't truly
understand followed by periods of growth
and so we think about these long
doubling times but I'm thinking about it
more recently as long periods of stasis
followed by brief periods of activity
and so it's a different mode of life
than we typically observe in the surface
biosphere
okay thank you
um and so what are the unknowns that
we're trying to understand with respect
to life in the Deep biosphere
yeah I think building on um some of
these questions about what is different
between a surface and a subsurface uh
Community
um uh for the fungi some of the
questions are are you know what kind of
biosynthetic Pathways do they have to be
able to
um acquire uh these nutrients or or
metabolize what's there so
um you know there could be different
ways of processing the limited resources
that are there as Maggie mentions we
they these are probably in stasis for a
long time and then when there is a
resource available you want to be able
to be as efficient as you can and
obtaining that and so that might be some
of the differences maybe those are
subtle but maybe those are more dramatic
types of um enzymes or new enzymes or
new versions of enzymes that can that
can process the material uh differently
um and
um you know it's really about Scavenging
fungi don't make their own food right so
they have to scavenge that car carbon
from something else and so I think
trying to understand how that
um how that evolved is is is part of it
you know what's different and at the
same time you know in we know that in in
say extreme or other extreme
environments like in in Ocean
environments or in um very salty
environments you know fungi can um
uh you know a bunch are important maybe
parts of parts of those communities they
often form biofilms to adhere to
surfaces and that allows them to kind of
maybe be a like an initial starting
point of a of a community or colony and
so those those fungi grow filamentously
they can grow with these sort of long
long threads and those threads can be
important parts of establishing the the
community and so I think thinking about
this is more than just one organism in
some place but really communities of
organisms
um and and how those maybe have adapted
to these environments is is part of the
question so not trying to study it as a
whole uh entity
yeah so there are certainly a lot of
unknowns with the Deep subsurface
biosphere and I think metabolism and how
these organisms are persisting is a huge
open question for microorganisms in
addition to those fungi
um we see different modalities of life
we see organisms that certainly make
their own food
um and those that can hardly make their
own selves they're really streamlined so
they don't have the genes that you'd
expect them to have for organisms that
can make their own food how are they
serving as the base of a food chain and
are they functioning independently deep
underground or are they dependent on
surfacial fluxes or fluxes from other
places and so how isolated is that life
um I think we have a fair amount of
evidence that we have microbial
consortia happening so we have
codependency of different organisms with
each other I mean obviously we're
interested in this fungi bacteria
Consortium so that's a big open question
which we're starting to tackle with the
help of cfar thankfully
um and then the question I always get in
talks is how do they get there and so
this question of inoculation so where
are these microbes coming from when are
they getting inoculated so when we talk
about say an aquifer environment where
we know using geochemistry that the
water in that Aquaphor is maybe 10 000
years old or Worse maybe millions of
years old in fact maybe in the Canadian
Craton a billion years old older you
know so you get to these really big
numbers of time
and so if the water is on average that
old how old are the microorganisms that
are in that water and when did they get
introduced to that water and how on
Earth are they surviving in that water
for literally millions of years and so
those are huge questions we know that
there are cells there because we can
take samples and we can do that
aseptically and we can count the cells
in there
and we can sequence their DNA and we can
see what they're capable of doing and so
we know that they have activity but
understanding how they got there how
they might move around why we get
similar microbes on different continents
that are like kind of closely related
you know these are sort of
mind-blowingly large questions of
microbial ecology I mean classic
questions like dispersal and inoculation
um but they just they make a lot less
sense when you're thinking about
kilometers down and millions of years
old
so those those kinds of Frontiers yeah
yeah little questions
and this is all incredibly fascinating
but
scientific curiosity aside why is it
that we want to study and understand
this deep biosphere
uh to the practical
well certainly the sort of base level
statement of why the Deep subsurface
biosphere is important is it's the
second largest active reservoir of
carbon in the biosphere compared to
terrestrial plants and so it is
incredibly large but those numbers vary
a lot depending on how you count the
cells because obviously we cannot count
you know every microbe in every spot on
the planet so refining those numbers is
a big task but every time we've done it
to date we end up with numbers that are
like gigantic so it's far more carbon
than is in like animals it's more carbon
than is in the Aquatic biospheres in the
ocean no one would question whether or
not you should study the Aquatic
biospheres of the ocean
um and so yeah so it's it's big
but big doesn't matter if it's not
connected probably right and so the next
question I mean maybe big is just
important broadly but we are humans we
are impatient and we are concerned about
things that are interacting with us
and so
you know as I referenced thinking about
the history of the deep biosphere when
we interact with the Deep biosphere it's
clear that we can perturb those systems
um and in terms of sort of thinking
about the future oil and gas extraction
is a thing we're certainly perturbing
those systems
um we also are going to be increasingly
dependent on the Deep subsurface for our
Clean Energy Technologies so things like
carbon sequestration involve injecting
CO2 down these same holes they're doing
it at high pressure they're probably
killing a lot of bugs but they're
depending on mineralization reactions to
occur they're depending on that carbon
to get sequestered and we don't have a
good sense necessarily of how the
microbial biosphere might hinder or help
those processes the other thing in clean
energy right now is this concept of
hydrogen storage so ways to keep clean
energy in sort of the places you wanted
at different times we also know that
microbes like to eat hydrogen
um particularly subsurface microbes and
so thinking about how that's going to
play out and what kind of an impact that
might have is is kind of a huge deal
we know that say CO2 comes out of the
deep biosphere in the form of Springs
right if you've ever had carbonated
Spring Water that's the Deep subsurface
biosphere bubbling at you right so we
know that there are natural fluxes
coming out and we know that there are
natural fluxes going in but the
quantification of those fluxes has is
hard is quite frankly hard and
quantifying those things while we mess
with them is even harder and so I'd say
they're a real practical applications
both for
you know practical things like Mining
and
um things
um but also for the future of our
civilizations with
clinologies
yeah I think I mean Maggie covered uh
exactly the same those are really big
questions that we'd like to understand I
think just
um within that we know there there are
certain cases where fungi are that are
key interactors and some of those
hydrocarbon
um seats or hydrocarbon and uh and oil
interactions and so whether or not the
fungi
um are are part of that cycling and
Metabolism deep there deep deep
underground is really important to
understand so we can we can start on we
can start to make predictions about how
things will change as we as we alter
that or or start to provide different
kinds of storage underground so I think
um
yeah there are practical Parts about
what kind of microbial processes
biological processes are occurring and
who are the microbes that are there and
if we
um if we inoculate with surface
um microbes accidentally how is that
going to change some of the properties
of what uh we think is going to happen
when things are underground so those are
perhaps
further practical ways that we'll use
that knowledge
yeah so I mean we've touched on this
maybe I'll push a little farther on this
line of questioning and just ask that as
you've mentioned this is a huge
reservoir of carbon and when people
think of reservoirs of carbon we often
think of the impact on climate so does
this deep biosphere present additional
risks or opportunities with respect to
mitigation of climate change
yeah I mean I sort of walked all over
this in the last one but I I think and I
think the the funding agencies have
gotten this and I think there's a
there's a there's a move right now to
try to better understand
essentially what direction the Deep
subsurface biosphere is going to push us
is it going to help us sequester carbon
or store hydrogen or is it going to hurt
us in those processes and like if you
look into industry you know if we think
about
um Reservoir souring the the battle
there so if you go to an oil and gas
well they are throwing all sorts of
biocides down these Wells trying to kill
things right and so it's like always the
goal is don't stimulate the microbes and
kill them when they bloom and I am not
convinced that that's the most
productive approach because often you
can't kill them and so how can how can
we evaluate the impact that microbes are
likely to have based on our knowledge of
the deep subsurface and better
understand how to work more say
copacetically with those microbial
communities instead of having this
antagonistic uh fight right we're never
going to win the fight against a
biosphere that large uh I mean I know
humans like to pick fights and win
fights but there's too many microbes and
they're too capable of doing things that
we cannot do and so I'm inclined to
think about sort of more Positive
forward-thinking Solutions of
cooperation with our deep subsurface
biospheres uh rather than just trying to
kill it
but we have to understand how it's going
to respond before we can harness that
potential power
yeah and I think that power can be
important if we if we also think about
how we might better mitigate waste
that's on the surface maybe the microbes
that are existing in the subsurface are
are more efficient or have you know
again novel Pathways for processing uh
some of these materials so like
hydrocarbon so we can we can go to
hydrocarbon seeps or tar pits and look
at the types of of microbes that live
there and again trying to study them as
a consortia as a community not just
individuals
um is is important part of that but but
with those communities and with the
genes or the gene products that are that
we can find there do we do we have new
Tools in being able to develop
um you know ways to sequester
um you know toxins better from the
environment or
um you know remediate remediate soils
that are contaminated with diesel fuel
things like that where we can start to
use the properties that these organisms
have to survive and apply them in a more
directed way and again you know there
are examples of that already where we we
on we find
um you know contamination in I think a
diesel fuel dump and we're trying to
prevent that from happening as Maggie
mentioned we might try to put biocides
in different places but also trying to
understand what is it that what what are
the biochemical processes that these
organisms are inducing and can we
um uh you know can we tune them or and
use them for different uh different
other processes like I'm I I think that
um
we need lots of different solutions for
the complexities of of the challenges we
have today and I think that ignoring or
you know another very large reservoir of
biodiversity uh we know we do that at
our Peril of not being able to to to
learn from some of the innovations that
those microbes probably have evolved so
we hope that that can also be a uh
another Frontier
uh fantastic thank you so much so I mean
this work that you're doing together is
really focused on the subsurface
biosphere but I guess I'm curious are
there implications for this work that go
beyond the subsurface biosphere
absolutely and so my first foray is into
thinking about the Deep subsurface
biosphere were funded by NASA and so one
of the key reasons or one motivation for
studying the Deep subsurface biosphere
is that the subsurface is actually kind
of a nice place especially if your
surface is not such a nice place and so
when we think about the habitability of
other planets or planetary bodies near
and far there's often this problem with
radiation on the surface so if you think
about Mars it doesn't have the
atmosphere that we have and it's getting
bombarded and so we know that the
surface is cold and it's got a lot of
radiation happening and it's not so
friendly
um at this moment and we also know that
there are things like probably liquid
water water there are minerals that
could provide some energy there are
reservoirs of things that could be
useful and so this is true on places is
like Mars and we're trying to constrain
that and better understand if there
could be a modern reservoir of life or
if there could be a past
um
there was life in the subsurface of
these other planetary systems it's also
true and there's a huge emphasis
currently on the icy moons and so when
you think about the oceans in beneath
the ice in Europa or Enceladus or even
Titan although that's a little deep
um you're talking about interfaces and
you're thinking about some of the same
geochemical gradients but on those very
cold places those subsurface places are
closer to the warmer bits of those moons
and so you have a little bit more hope
and you've got liquid water and you have
things to work with and so we study
analog environments on this planet to
help us better understand the potential
for life on not this planet so big
implications for elsewhere
yeah fantastic super super fascinating
um so for now I mean thank you both for
sharing your insights with us uh we have
a number of questions coming in from the
audience so I'd like to turn to some of
those
um first we'll start off with an area
that I think is on lots of people's
minds they're listening to this which is
about how this relates to origins of
light so I mean a couple of few
questions together here one is do you
have thoughts on a biogenesis do you
think that life first began on the
surface then migrated down or began in
deep environments and migrated up and
perhaps sort of a tangential lens on
this is if we're talking about very slow
pace of life in the subsurface does that
allow us to in one way look back in time
and what does that tell us about early
life and the origins of life
oh that's a big question
um
let's see so the origin of life
is complex of course and is a thing we
definitely like to get invites about
um
components of the deep subsurface
biosphere are potentially really helpful
for bringing together the biochemical or
the then chemical the now biochemical
species that you might need uh to form
life
um
one challenge with having the evolution
of life or having the origin of Life
occur in a deep subsurface environment
is that slow slow speed
um
even with modern organisms the rate of
evolution
in the subsurface
does not track with our understanding of
rates of evolution of surface organisms
and so we have a recent example of
um a Cosmopolitan subsurface organism
who's been found across the globe in
different sites that have not been in
contact in millions of years and
sequencing the genomes of that organism
this is not my work this is a study
um that I read and was very interested
in
the genomes are different and so there's
been some change and they're not just
like all inoculated from some subsurface
researcher being sloppy
um but they're not different enough to
be explained for the time that they've
been sequestered and so it looks like
Evolution may be happening at a far
slower rate
um and that's not fantastic if you're
trying to make the large-scale
innovations that you need to go from
like that first Proto not quite life to
something that's much more Dynamic
um I don't work on the origin of Life
purposefully because it's mind-blowing
and I'm not entirely certain how you
know when you have the right answer
yeah fantastic thank you and can I just
ask Jason
I mean you deal with fungi with you
which are eukaryotic do you have any
comments on this from a eukaryotic
perspective which is maybe one step
farther along with microbes
yeah I
um I mean I think
I don't know if we have I have any other
insights beyond that you know these are
protected areas each so they might be
slow growing but these these spaces
might might provide some Clues to the
history because you have sort of old
lineages that might have still persisted
and you might be able to get some Clues
from that because they are in such a
slow uh slow reproductive
um modes I guess but um
yeah it's it's picked the idea that
perhaps there's there's a better
environment uh than a really harsh
surface would be the the best I could
imagine for those initial Parts but you
know you kind of need water for some of
for some of these things to be able to
um to really reproduce it at a fast
enough rate so I guess I'm
um it's hard it's hard for me to project
back what I think the fungi what those
early Proto fungi would have looked like
in a subsurface environment we mostly
think about that kind of in a more
aquatic terrestrial interface but
that the clues that we might glean from
uh samples deep there might tell us more
about lineages that have been around for
a long time and that's what I hope we
could get some more clues to
yeah wonderful thank you
so turning to another question on a
slightly different topic so you say how
the Deep biosphere might interact with
sequestered carbon or hydrogen is a big
unknown in this area so is there any
preliminary research suggesting how it
might impact carbon sequestration so in
other words what is the current best
guess
yeah so in part it's unknown to me
because I haven't yet worked on this
topic but there are certainly
geomicrobiologists thinking about
um interactions between carbon
sequestration and
um the Deep biosphere so there was a big
pilot
um in Iceland that has been studied
um fairly extensively and so they did
sort of trial uh CO2 injections and are
monitoring both the mineral growth
underground so making uh nice carbonate
minerals to keep that really stuck
underground and also monitoring the
microbial populations and thinking about
um how they're interacting in that space
and I think those results are are
positive I mean you've you've got you've
got microbes that are involved I mean
microbes biomineralize carbonates and so
there's reason to think that some of
those processes
um might actually help with forming
permanent minerals underground
um I don't think there have been results
yet but I know the that there's a pretty
decent project going on locally in
Illinois here looking at trial carbon
sequestration so essentially it's very
local carbon sequestration so it's like
a power plant and then they have an
injection well like right next door and
there's multiple instances of this and
there are microbiologists who are
monitoring the subsurface biosphere
within those aquifers concurrently to
try to understand the effects that it's
having a little farther afield
excellent thank you so
I'm going to turn to another question
I'm going to paraphrase a little bit but
um in the analyzes you've done uh either
Maggie or Jason
um what do we know about lithotrophic
bacteria so in other words bacteria with
their own metabolic Machinery to obtain
energy from inorganic sources of carbon
so what do we know about these where are
they getting this energy from the
subsurface environment where there is no
water where the water may be observed
um and are we able to relate these two
specific types of bacteria and archaea
in the Deep subsurface
sure sure yeah absolutely I'll I'll I
keep talking Jason cut me off you'd like
to see you're good
so first of all I'd like to clear up a
misconception because my mentor
Barbershop Lawler would kill me if I
didn't you're not short on water in the
subsurface so there's plenty of water in
the subsurface we're not necessarily
talking about
um really arid environments except in
places where the pore sizes are so small
that it's really prohibiting water those
are places you might have heard of
things like fracking
um to open up those spaces to let the
gas out but also to let water in and
they do Bloom like crazy when you put
the water back in so that's that's the
limiting factor in those systems in
terms of what we've learned about
microbial metabolism underground and
lithotrophy I mean it's a key focus of
my research and so I'm very excited
about it what you find are broad
metabolic capabilities in particular we
have a phenomenal ability to use things
like iron and manganese so the ability
to use minerals so say an iron oxide
like we use oxygen so using that as a
terminal electron acceptor in their
metabolism
the widespread ability to fix inorganic
carbon and so we see many many organisms
deep underground have the capability of
fixing carbon so making biomass out of
CO2 or bicarbonate and there's even a
convergence on which biochemical pathway
they use to do that and it's the one
that uses the least energy which
shouldn't be so surprising a little bit
paradoxically though is there's also a
huge capability in common commonly
observed capability for organisms to fix
nitrogen so N2
and that's really energetically
expensive but you can imagine that that
might be something you need to do if
you're living in a place that doesn't
have more bioavailable forms of of
nitrogen
um but we see a broad broad complement
of metabolic capability and widespread
potential for lithotrophy early in the
Deep subsurface biosphere there was this
concept of of the slimes so the
subsurface lithotrophic I forget but
those were hydrogen-based ecosystems
um so thinking about sort of different
reservoirs and different electron
acceptors and donors
um very common
absolutely common
maybe I'll just say that like um I can't
really speak to many specifics about the
fungi because we don't really have
cultures of very many things from down
there and so and and we're only now
starting to generate try to generate
some of these metagenomic focused
um data sets with in this collaboration
so I um I do know that on the surface in
some of the environments again I've
talked a little bit about drier
environments where there's been these
Extreme More extreme
um
uh adaptations perhaps we do see like
lots of different Scavenging the
different uh different abilities to
acquire iron for example
um that have been that have evolved or
been acquired by those lineages so
um we're kind of projecting that in
those kind of resource scarce surface
environments we might see similar
properties
um in in the types of fungi that we can
identify in the Deep subsurface
yeah so that's a great segue to this
next question which is
is there anything or what has most
surprised you in your recent work
I I can talk about so again one General
thing that we're finding is there are
certain fungi that are like really good
at lots of hard to live places right
there maybe not the fastest Growers but
they kind of are the
um uh they're not weeds so much because
they don't weeds we think of a sort of
fast growing plants that end up in
spaces that that aren't that aren't so
habitable but they're really um we find
certain these we call these black fungi
or these melonized fungi because they
have this kind of really dark
um cell walls they we tend to find them
in lots of places with like high salt
and low water and so I think that
understanding how that interacts of the
melanin that's in those those cells is
actually an important part of um their
survival
um that's been shown that that's
important when they go to spay we can
send these fungi to space and the
melanin
um is an important part of their
survival there as well so
um uh what I think is interesting is
this sort of this repeated theme around
certain certain kinds of successes of of
certain of groups of fungi and we're
sort of seeing them in these
um places where there aren't a lot of
other uh uh other fungi growing and so I
I'm
want to understand better what what
what's the basis for that and how that
evolved
and I'll say that my surprise is of late
have come out of my work in caves and
that's specifically of my student Matt
Solinski
um and that is we've been looking at
Carbon metabolism in these more shallow
of the deep subsurface biospheres and
using that and doing that using lipid
biomarker based tools so this is your
cellular membrane and what you build it
out of and what what we found is that
the microbes that are living in some of
the biofilms in particularly lava caves
so these Lava Tubes
um are fixing an awful lot of their own
carbon and we're seeing that
isotopically which isn't the expectation
I would have gone in with because
there's a decent amount of organic
carbon in the fluids that are bathing
those biofilms and so I went into it
with this null with this hypothesis that
we were going to see more organic carbon
consumption in surfacial sites and less
progressively with depth and what I've
seen and what Matt proved and what has
been shown in the literature several
times thereafter is that many of these
shallow organisms can actually fix
carbon and do so regularly
um so it's like being offered a
hamburger and instead chewing on a kale
stem
voluntarily which is would not be my
prediction but it seems to be what they
do
excellent so
I'm gonna ask you another question um
what the world and technology in general
has changed a lot over the last 50 years
so what can we and by we I mean you do
today in your fields that we couldn't do
50 years ago and how does that change
what we can do in this field and how you
approach this work
maybe I'll I'll take the first part I
think um so just the technology that's
changed that's that's kind of enabled in
the even the last 20 years of the
sensitivity of genomic sequencing
um of the the way that we can apply PCR
and sequencing to really get this really
fine scale
um inventory of the DNA that's present
and hopefully with the right kinds of
controls the living organisms that are
actually found in in those environments
and so that plus again improvements in
microscopy and the ability to really
visualize what's there I think and label
things
um and visualize that has really changed
how we can understand what what might
have been a black box where where we you
know cultured something and you know
took some sample culture and looked to
what grew right now we're able to really
get in there and measure
um everything that that might be present
in that sample and as the technology has
gotten less expensive that's also
enabled more people to participate in
that work and that's really I think
allowed
um different kinds of Innovations and
different kinds of ideas and so I I just
I think that's opened up
um more people trying to address these
questions in in interesting environments
and so I think that's that's really
Advanced our fields yeah I'll say that I
feel incredibly lucky to be able to do
this research at this moment in time I
remember you know some many years ago as
an undergrad sort of working on uh sort
of earlier versions of DNA sequencing
technology where like you really fought
for every base pair in every sequence
whereas now you know we're just gonna
throw in a big giant many millions of
reads run and it's no big thing and
it'll be great it'll probably work so
um so that is a huge Innovation and it
means we can do an incredible amount of
new research the other technological
development I'd say that's really
starting to shape some of the the Deep
microbial work
um bacterial archaeal Works sorry Jason
I know a lot of fungis are microbes too
um are things like flow cytometry and so
getting those tiny little cells all by
themselves so that we can sequence them
and
um understand what they're doing is
really novel and important and then even
things like synthetic biology where
we're thinking about using those Gene
capabilities for good hopefully
okay well unfortunately that is all the
time we have for today I really want to
thank everyone for joining us and I
especially like to thank Maggie and
Jason for sharing their time and
insights with our Global audience please
everyone visit our website cpar.ca to
find out more about this event series
the work of our programs and to youth
recordings from this and previous talks
reporting of this talk should be posted
early next week in addition I'd like to
invite all of you to our next event in
the CVR virtual talk series it will
actually be a hybrid event called AI
agents Among Us causality and
reinforcement learning you'll be able to
join us either in person in Montreal or
virtually from anywhere in the world on
March 23rd so please visit our website
seafar.c for further details or to
register and to everyone and to our
speakers thank you very much and until
next time
foreign
[Music]